(voix de soldat)
- C'est une rare incursion dans
un monde qu'ils ne souhaitent
pas trop dévoiler, celui
des combattants étrangers
en Ukraine.
Le Canadien Jay, nom fictif
pour préserver son identité,
nous entraîne dans les tranchées
creusées autour du centre
de formation de son équipe
en appui à la défense
territoriale, l'équivalent de
la réserve.
Jay est arrivé en Ukraine il y
a une semaine. Il a pris un vol
de Toronto à Londres. Il a
ensuite fait le trajet jusqu'à
Lviv avec des combattants
britanniques.
Dans ce sous-sol de Kiev,
un instructeur finlandais
forme des civils a
Selon la défense ukrainienne,
environ 20 000 combattants
étrangers auraient rejoint
l'armée et des milliers d'autrei
logistique.
KENETH GREGG,
instructeur finlandais
"On ne pense pas à notre propre
vie dans le contexte actuel.",
dit-il.
Selon la défense territoriale
ukrainienne, il y de mille combs
dans le pays en ce moment.
Plus de la moitié, environ 550,
seraient dans la grande région
de la capitale, Kiev.
(tirs)
Les Canadiens seraient
d'ailleurs si nombreux qu'ils
auraient leur propre bataillon
de la légion étrangère
en Ukraine. Jay aimerait qu'il y
en ait davantage et surtout,
que le Canada en fasse plus
sur le terrain même si
les risques sont grands.
tout, Jay compte offrir
ses services jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre.
C'est tout pour la visite.
Jay veut retourner aider
le peuple ukrainien.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Lviv, en Ukraine